if you think of earning potential as the
total amount of value that you can
exchange with the marketplace you're
going to be compensated in some way in
money and experience some makeup of that
if you come in to a business smaller
percentages money then you are providing
more value than you're being compensated
for and if you in a good company you'll
be compensated back in excess of what
that experience is that will further
increase your earning potential and then
you can even trade that earning
potential for again a bigger chunk of
cash but you still have Goodwill built
into the exchange with the business